um so you would text darzie what would
you say i go
uh you tell at the audience who darzie
is oh he's just a
uh once upon a time not even an official
like he wasn't an official
official yeah you know what you know it
was a a love affair i had in australia
a long time ago she's had a lot of love
affairs
no i haven't not more than you mine
weren't love though mine were
sexual affairs oh okay yeah but you've
had like feelings and stuff
international too very nice like
internet like you when you were reading
the emails last night it was like really
touching in my heart
oh yeah that [ __ ] really broke me up
yeah she brought up some old emails
boyfriend so i was looking through not
intentionally i'm not searching for old
love letters that's weird
so yeah but it's like when you walk into
a room right your bedroom
yeah and she's on the computer and she's
crying oh
crying and she's just like i just you
know
um this email reminded me of this you
know the guy
and you know i have regrets as well and
regrets and all that stuff and it's just
like
it's so touching that she has those
types of
deep feelings with four people you know
i whereas for me i don't
if i read it if i read an email from an
ex-girlfriend i would have
well i'd never they've never emailed me
but if they if i had one
i'd just be i would get on it and go how
do i get out of this
yeah or like where's the delete or do i
forward i don't know how to do it
that's exactly how i feel for most of
them actually like
my my ex alex he's a [ __ ] monster i i
i need if i happen to stumble onto
something old that he had written me
like i swear to god
i start i have a mustache sweat
immediately like i
he's he's very he's diabolical to me
anyways no but
i was looking for an old uh children's
story that i had written
in as a teenager oh by the way really
good
and so um my sister was like hey i think
if you search your old emails
and look for you know so this this word
in your email specifically um you'll
find it and sure enough i found it
but when i found that i also found much
older emails from
the the ex that i had before bobby who i
was with for almost five years
and um it was i made a lot of mistakes
and
and the very last thing that he said to
me was
he wrote me while i was we had already
broken up but he wrote me while i was in
australia on vacation with
somebody else somebody knew and he
basically said
like i i can we be friends
like you are like [ __ ] all of this [ __ ]
all the feelings like you were my friend
first and foremost i love you we shared
a life together
and i don't care i basically i don't
care i want you in my life
and it yeah you
decorated my life
but that didn't happen we didn't stay
friends because um
the he eventually found um somebody else
who
was not okay with any type of
friendships with me which is fine i
totally respect that and so that's it
but it made me emotional
and that's what bobby walked into in the
room i was like yeah
like i don't think of like emotional
things like that i think of like
you know little incidences like like one
time i was i can't say her name but um
she was she would play with my pee pee
i don't know i was fully erect okay good
yeah and um
she was doing it like robotically oh i
know what you're talking about
you're the stick shift yeah and i go
yeah and i go it's not a joystick you're
like you're not playing a video game
and she tears came out of her eyes and
she goes
thanks a lot
right and then like we wouldn't she
didn't hook up with me for like two
weeks after that
i loved it but i remember thinking
they're like i just said don't do it
that way like what
how did you say it though okay here i am
i didn't say it right away so why don't
you start doing it and i'm going to show
you my facial expression okay we're in
the dark
yeah but yeah if you just go set the
stage set the stage
yeah so i'm we're in the bed we're in
the bed yeah it'll collapse yeah
we know we're not doing that so just
just do the just do the penis thing
hold on yeah okay i want to be in it i
want to be in this room okay go ahead
all right i'm looking at you and
straighten the eyes because i want a
romantic
um yeah it's
not a [ __ ] joystick you're not
playing a video game
say thanks thanks a lot thanks so much
and action
do you like it you don't have don't
improvise
this is an error this is an iron
this is an aaron sorkin project you have
to do it by the lines all right don't
improvise all right
[ __ ] go ahead okay yeah yeah
what am i what the [ __ ] am i lebron
james
it's not a [ __ ] joystick it's not a
video game
thanks a lot
[Applause]
and she's she's probably going to hear
that right now and the person that's
into this
i think i think people do no no we
didn't say name who cares yeah yeah oh
there's santino
are you ready yeah put out next to them
so just i'm not gonna say i'm on the
podcast
try your best try your best